[Música]
este es el sars co2
pertenece a la familia de los
coronavirus y fue nombrado así por las
espinas similares a una corona que están
en su superficie del sar scott 2 puede
producir kobe 19 una infección viral
contagiosa que ataca principalmente tu
garganta y tus pulmones que ocurre con
tu cuerpo cuando contraes el coronavirus
exactamente qué hace que desarrollo es
neumonía
como funcionaría una eventual vacuna
[Música]
el coronavirus debe infectar células
vivas para reproducirse veamos un poco
más de cerca dentro del virus el
material genético contiene la
información para hacer más copias de sí
mismo una cápside le provee una
envoltura protectora al material
genético a medida que el virus viaja
entre las personas que infecta una
envoltura exterior le permite al virus
infectar las células al unirse con la
membrana externa de las mismas hay
espinas de moléculas proteicas que se
proyectan desde esta envoltura tanto el
virus de la gripe común como el nuevo
corona virus usan estas espinas como una
llave para entrar dentro de las células
de tu cuerpo
allí el virus se apropia de la
maquinaria interna de las células y las
reprograman para que creen los
componentes del nuevo virus cuando una
persona contagiada habla 12o estornuda
las gotículas que llevan el virus pueden
llegar a tu boca o nariz y luego pasar a
tus pulmones una vez está dentro de tu
cuerpo el virus entra en contacto con
las células de tu garganta
o pulmón es una espina del virus se
inserta en una molécula receptora de la
membrana de una de tus células
saludables es como una llave en una
cerradura esta acción permite que el
virus ingrese a tu célula
un virus de gripe común contenido en una
envoltura hecha de tu membrana celular
viajaría hasta el núcleo de la célula
que alberga todo el material genético el
coronavirus en cambio no necesita entrar
al núcleo de la célula huésped puede
acceder a partes de la célula huésped
llamadas ribosomas los ribosomas
utilizan la información genética del
virus para generar proteínas virales
como las espinas que están en la
superficie del virus una estructura de
empaque lleva las espinas en vesículas
que se unen con la capa exterior de la
célula es decir la membrana celular
todas las partes necesarias para crear
un nuevo virus están reunidas justo
debajo de la membrana celular luego el
nuevo virus comienza a emerger desde la
membrana celular ya con el virus que se
esparce en tu cuerpo como desarrollas
síntomas de neumonía
para explicarlo debemos dar un vistazo a
tus pulmones cada pulmón tiene secciones
separadas llamadas lóbulos normalmente
cuando respiras el aire se mueve
libremente a través de la tráquea luego
lo hace a través de grandes tubos
llamados bronquios a través de tubos más
pequeños llamados bronquiolos y
finalmente a través de pequeñas bolsas
llamadas alvéolos tus vías respiratorias
así como los alvéolos son flexibles y
elásticas cuando inhalas cada bolsa de
aire se infla como un pequeño globo y
cuando exhalas se desinfla pequeños
vasos sanguíneos llamados capilares
rodean el alveolo
el oxígeno del aire que respiras pasa a
los capilares luego el dióxido de
carbono de tu cuerpo pasa de tus
capilares a los alvéolos para que tus
pulmones puedan liberarse de él cuando
exhalas sus vías respiratorias capturan
la mayor parte de los gérmenes en el
moco que está en tu tráquea bronquios y
bronquiolos en un cuerpo sano cilios
similares a cabellos presentes en los
tubos empujan constantemente el moco y
los gérmenes afuera de tus vías
respiratorias
donde los puedes expulsar al toser
normalmente las células de tu sistema
inmune
atacan los virus y gérmenes que logran
atravesar el moco y los cilios que
logran entrar a los alveolos sin embargo
si tu sistema inmune se debilita como
ocurre con el contagio de el coronavirus
el virus puede superar la capacidad de
las células de tu sistema inmune es
entonces cuando tus bronquios y alvéolos
se inflaman mientras tu sistema inmune
ataca el virus que se prolifera la
inflamación puede hacer que tus alveolos
se llenen de fluido lo que
dificulta tu cuerpo obtener el oxígeno
que necesita
podrías desarrollar neumonía loval qué
ocurre cuando un lóbulo de tus pulmones
resulta afectado también se podría
generar una bronconeumonía que afecta a
varias zonas de ambos pulmones la
neumonía puede causar dificultad para
respirar dolor de pecho tos fiebre
escalofríos confusión dolor de cabeza o
muscular y fatiga también puede llevar a
complicaciones más graves como falla
respiratoria esto ocurre cuando respirar
se vuelve tan difícil que necesitas una
máquina llamada respirador para ayudarte
a lograrlo estos son los dispositivos
que salvan vidas y cuya producción están
aumentando las compañías que desarrolles
o no los síntomas depende de muchos
factores tu edad o una condición
existente aunque todo esto suena
aterrador los esfuerzos para que se
desarrolle una vacuna contra el
coronavirus aumentan
los estudios de otros tipos de
coronavirus han llevado a los
investigadores a asumir que las personas
que se han recuperado de una infección
con sharp corp 2 podrían estar
protegidas de un nuevo contagio por un
periodo de tiempo pero esa teoría
tendría que ser respaldada por evidencia
empírica y otros estudios sugieren lo
contrario hay enfoques diferentes sobre
una vacuna potencial contra el
coronavirus la idea básica es que
recibas una versión leve del virus
la vacuna expondría a tu cuerpo a una
versión que es muy débil para generar
una infección pero lo suficientemente
fuerte para estimular una respuesta del
sistema inmune en cuestión de semanas
las células de tu sistema inmune
generarán anticuerpos específicos para
éste coronavirus o para sus espinas
proteicas tus anticuerpos se sujetan al
virus para así prevenir que se inserte
en tus células luego tu sistema inmune
responde a las señales de los
anticuerpos consumiendo y destruyendo
así los puñados de virus
si más adelante te contagias del virus
real tu cuerpo lo reconocerá y destruirá
en otras palabras tu sistema inmune
ahora está preparado recolectar la
evidencia sobre la posibilidad seguridad
y efectividad de una vacuna es una de
las razones que ha demorado el
desarrollo de la misma es una carrera
contra el tiempo para desarrollar una
vacuna en medio de la pandemia cada paso
en este proceso toma meses o incluso
años una vacuna contra el ébola rompió
récords al estar lista en 5 años
la esperanza es que se pueda desarrollar
una en un tiempo récord de 12 a 18 meses
aunque esto tomará tiempo quédate en
casa si puedes para así proteger a los
más vulnerables
no olvides lavar tus manos durante al
menos 20 segundos y tantas veces como
sea posible qué crees que pasaría si no
lo haces durante todo un año bueno
desaparece una historia para otro
episodio de qué pasaría si
[Música]